we've known him for a long time
when he said he was going to be a proud
union president we knew he would be
and he delivered
president biden stabilized america and
is taking us in a new direction that is
a net benefit for not just the building
trades but all american workers
president biden chose to invest in
america and not divide it he has
prioritized working people workforce
development wages health and safety
retirement pensions more than any
president in our lifetime he and his
administration have and repeatedly
publicly the importance of davis bacon
collective bargaining and poas
[Applause]
in the first months of his
administration he passed what i consider
to be the most important and impactful
piece of legislation for the poor the
working class of this country in my
lifetime the american rescue plan
he has helped reclaim jobs lost from the
pandemic he has expanded the child tax
credit child care tax credits and
unemployment insurance he delivered
better access to affordable health care
and to top it off multi-employer pension
reform that the building trades has been
fighting for for decades
but he didn't stop there like like many
before him he said he would get an
infrastructure bill but unlike the
others he got the job done
[Applause]
but he didn't stop there a national
labor relations board that actually
cares about working people done an
executive order project labor agreements
for federal construction projects done
new rules of strengthening davis bacon
done
getting this pandemic under control and
getting access to vaccines and testing
getting our economy moving done done
done
[Applause]
and just last week we can proudly say
that thanks to his leadership in the
actions of his administration not only
our jobs up unemployment down but the
construction industry is finally back to
the level of employment we had in
february of 2020 before the pandemic
started
yes brothers and sisters we're back
but these wins are more than us
investing in america reclaiming not just
jobs but good jobs rising wages
increasing benefits all while expanding
opportunities to more working families
this is what he delivers for america
president biden did more in his first
term in the first year and a half of his
first term than presidents do in their
whole terms all working americans
especially the ones struggling or
unfairly marginalized
he knew he needed a new direction that
required more than just getting by and
rebuilding what we lost he knows what we
needed to build back better a system
that we had before built back better
than the system we had before
he knew it was not enough to return to
pre-pandemic times you know america and
our and our future deserve better and he
delivered so please stand and welcome
our friend the favorite son of the
commonwealth of pennsylvania
and the great state of delaware brothers
sisters the president of the united
states joe biden
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
it's good to be home
wow
[Applause]
thank you thank you thank you thank you
you better stop i'll start believing it
please have a seat if you have one
it's good to be home
[Applause]
you know i look out there and uh
i see an awful lot of you who uh as they
say uh
in uh claim on delaware who bring me to
the dance
and i i know i really mean it
there is no exaggeration
i'd not be standing here
without labor without union union labor
folks
as you used to say
when i was a senator if you excuse a
point of personal privilege
before i turn to my main remarks
i'd like to have to
briefly address the horrifying reports
of the atrocities taking place in
ukraine
and the steps the united states is
taking to respond
in close coordination with our allies
and our partners
and i'm sure you've seen the pictures
from buka and outside just outside of
kiev
bodies left in streets as russian troops
withdrew
some shot in the back of the head with
their hands tied behind their backs
civilians executed
cold blood
bodies dumped into mass graves a sense
of brutality and humanity
left for all the world to see
unapologetically
there's nothing less happening than
major war crimes responsible nations
have to come together to hold these
perpetrators accountable and together
with our allies and our partners we're
going to keep raising the economic cost
and ratchet up the pain for putin and
further increase russia's economic
isolation
[Applause]
oh
steps
we've already taken
are predicted to shrink russia's gross
domestic product by double digits this
year alone
just in one year
our sanctions are lucky to wipe out the
last 15 years of russia's economic gains
and because we've cut russia off from
importing technologies like
semiconductors and encryption security
and critical components of quantum
technology that they need to compete in
the 21st century we're going to stifle
russia's ability and its economy to grow
for years to come folks this is the
united states
and we're taking additional steps in
lockstep with our allies and partners to
raise the economic pressure on putin
first the united states will impose full
blocking sanctions on spare bank by far
the largest financial institution in
russia and alpha bank is largest private
bank we're locking down any accounts any
funds that those banks hold in the
united states they'll not be able to
touch any of their money
they'll not be able to do any business
here and second i'm going to sign an
executive order that's going to ban any
new u.s investment in russia
more than 600 private sector companies
folks
corporate america is stepping up change
from mcdonald's to exxon they've left
the russian market on their own accord
600 of them think about that the private
businesses choosing to leave russia
rather than the risk being associated
with putin's brutal war
and this ban on investment is going to
make sure that new money can't come into
russia to replace what's left
so that russian economy doesn't feel the
loss and the loss of these businesses
for the long term third we're adding
more critical state-owned enterprises to
the list of fully blocked russian
companies these companies are major
revenue generators owned by russian the
government which putin uses a fund
himself and enables war in ukraine
they'll also be cut off from doing any
business with the united states
they'll not be able to access or use any
assets they have in the united states
and fourth
we along with our european allies are
adding the names on the list of russian
elites and their families that we're
sanctioning you see these yachts where
they're being picked up uh no think
about it think about the the incredible
amounts of money these oligarchs have
stolen
these yachts are hundreds millions and
millions of dollars
look
these oligarchs and their family members
are not allowed to hold on to their
wealth in europe and the united states
and keep these yachts worth hundreds of
millions of dollars their luxury
vacation homes while children in your
crane are being killed displaced
from their homes every single day and
finally we're continuing to supply
ukraine with the weapons resources they
need to defend their country
last friday
[Applause]
last friday we announced millions in
funding to procure new equipment for
ukraine
advanced drones laser-guided rocket
systems yesterday i signed another
package to send more javelin missiles
those shoulder-mounted missiles that can
take out tanks and armored vehicles
[Applause]
to keep getting an uninterrupted supply
to the ukrainian military
you know we won't be able to
advertise every piece of security we
give because our allies and partners are
supplying to ukraine through us
but advanced weapons and ammunition are
flowing in every single day and as you
may have seen yesterday on television
when the secretary of defense was being
cross-examined by one of
our
how can i say our congress persons
saying what have you done
and he basically looked at him and said
what the hell do you think we've done
why do you think you're able to fight
we've trained them and we've given them
the weapons
that's what's happening
look
[Applause]
thanks
to the bravery the grit and the fighting
fighting spirit of the ukrainian people
russia has already failed in its initial
war aims russia wanted to take ukraine's
capital city keem and topless democracy
and elected government today keefe still
stands and that government still
presides
this fight is far from over
here's the point
this war could continue for a long time
but the united states will continue to
stand with ukraine the ukrainian people
in the fight for freedom
and i just want you to know that and by
the way
if i got to go to war i'm going with you
guys
i
mean i want to talk about
[Applause]
i want to talk about
what i'm here today to talk about
you women are men
in the american
union movement
remember you know
when the fair labor standards act was
first passed everybody said you can have
unions it didn't say that
it says we should
have more unions we should
american labor the building trade unions
president mcgarvey by the way
dad jack where are you
jack i tell you what dad as they say in
southern dela you've done good with this
boy
[Applause]
and you know uh
i i just know
jack's a philadelphia guy you know why
he uh i just asked sean i said where he
said well he's
down the shore now if you're from
philadelphia
jersey you go to the shore if you're
from northern delaware you go to the
shore
a little bit further south you go to the
beach
you go to the beach you can always tell
where someone's from and dad i ask
whether or not
whether or not you like my wife jill's
from philly still talks about broad
street
broad street run you know and you know
you see
and you know jeet yeah you know
uh
you know i had to learn to speak
philadelphia when i got married
but dad it's an honor to meet you from a
distance here thank you thank you very
much
look
[Applause]
it's good to be with you all i mean that
you know there's an old profession as i
said earlier you go home with them to
bring you to the dance
and you all you folks brought me to the
dance
and the people who brought me to the
dance were union workers not just
workers union workers ibw iron workers
boiler makers teamsters laborers
bricklayers masons plumbers and
pipefitters painters plasterers roofers
operating engineers steel
steel metal workers you all represented
in this room
and so many more who are not in the
building trades that are union members
across the country
i want to thank you for what you did to
support my election this last time out i
remember
going to a guy sitting down here a
little further to the right when i i
refused to i i wasn't going to introduce
my
my uh
my climate plan until i decided i was
going to speak to a guy from the ibw
because i wanted to make sure you all
knew what i was doing and why it not
only was good for
the environment but good for labor and i
sat down with that guy right there
and he thought about it he went out and
he talked to other people and uh and you
all stepped up
and i mean it sincerely
you're probably the biggest reason why
i'm standing here today
i've never forgotten not only what
you've done for me but more importantly
what you've done for this country
you're the ones who literally built this
country and that's not hyperbole
and you heard it a thousand times when i
was running for office that we're going
to build this economy not from the top
down anymore but from the middle up and
out that's how you build america because
we know that when the middle class does
well the poor have a way up and the
wealthy are just fine that's exactly
what we're doing and by the way
the reason there is a middle class is
because of unions
[Applause]
that's a fact
[Applause]
that's true
not only to provide a good living but
what you do more than anything my dad
used to say
you allow people to have dignity
the dignity of their work
to be treated with respect
when it comes time to rebuild the
economy
before i did anything as i said i talked
to you i laid out my plan for economic
growth i talked with a lot of the folks
sitting behind me here and others in the
union movement
and with your help
it was a darn good plan
and look at the results our economy
created
431 000 jobs in march
7.9 million since i became president
more jobs in 14 months than any
president of the history of america has
ever created because of you
unemployment's down to three six three
point six percent from six point four
when i took office the fastest decline
in unemployment to the start of term of
a president ever recorded because of you
and the economy grew 5.7 last year the
fastest growth in 40 years i know people
are still hurting i'm not i'm not
unaware of it as my dad would say every
time that price of the gas went up with
the pump guess what it was a
conversation on our kitchen table that
mattered it'd affect outcomes it
affected what we did
but in the process we were able to cut
the deficit by 360 billion dollars last
year and it's been a long tough stretch
but americans are back to work our
economy has gone from being on the mend
to being on the move it started with the
american rescue plan i took office in
the midst of the worst economic crisis
since the great depression you all
remember the lines of cars stretching
for miles waiting for a box of food to
be put in their trunk not just poor
folks folks across the board waiting for
that box of food
because the american rescue plan helped
41 million americans put food on their
table because of the american rescue
plan we helped keep a roof over the
heads of four million people
[Applause]
can you help get that plan passed four
million people were on the verge of
being an
it's
evicted
fact not a joke four million
rescue plan put money in the pockets of
hard-working americans who thought
through no fault of their own were in
trouble
giving families what my dad used to call
just a little bit of breathing room just
a little bit of breathing room because
of the rescue plan
we had the best year
of state and local growth in 20 years
adding back
467 000 jobs and educators firefighters
police officers who were laid off got
back in the job we made a job you made a
gigantic difference in addition because
of the rescue plan
320 000
construction jobs last year
325 000.
[Applause]
you're building america again
remember what i said
we're the only nation in the world has
come out of every serious problem we've
had stronger than when we went in
and there are now more construction jobs
today than we had before the pandemic
the leading financial firm moody's wall
street estimates that because of the
rescue plan four million more jobs were
created and unemployment is two percent
lower than it would have been had we
failed to act
but look that wasn't all we did to the
rescue plan we also included the law
called the butch lewis act
you know what it is most people don't
to ensure there's revival of america we
have held a promise
a promise
to secure a dignified retirement for
millions of workers and retirees all
across america protecting pensions you
all work so damn hard for you sacrifice
to secure and it didn't stop there
because
we can't compete for the jobs of the
21st century if you don't fix our
infrastructure that's why it was so
important to pass the bipartisan
infrastructure law you know
and now not only is it infrastructure
weak finally arrived
it's infrastructure decade
infrastructure
no for real
already
already as all of you know
we've announced nearly 5 billion to
improve 3 000 airports across 50 states
this year we've announced five billion
including 650 million this year alone so
lonnie stevens of the ibw get to work
building a national network of electric
vehicle charging stations 500 000.
we've announced
4.7 billion to cap and plug hundreds of
thousands of orphan wells and gas wells
spewing methane into the air creating
jobs as good as the jobs the folks dug
those wells got paid in the first place
same folks
folks
nearly 17 billion dollars for ports
waterways and dams
700 projects already announced across 50
states
52.5 billion for highways and road
repairs this year
5.4 billion for bridges this year
the i5 bridge over columbia river in
washington state
the i-95 bridge of west ham and
connecticut
the jefferson highway
u.s 61 east baton rouge parish in
louisiana
the list goes on
not only that
we're getting rid of poisonous lead
pipes and 10 million homes and 400 000
schools and child care centers
so kids and families can have drinking
water it doesn't poison them
look folks that this is america the
united states of america
we're investing 65 billion dollars to
deliver affordable high-speed internet
everywhere in america urban rural
suburban tribal communities
it can't be a country where a mother has
to pull with her child up in her car to
a mcdonald's parking lot to connect to
an internet so the kid can do their
homework
i mean think about that it's the united
states of america
look
this law puts an end to that and creates
thousands of jobs doing it good paying
jobs and look
[Applause]
what this means for all of you is jobs
good paying union jobs jobs you can
raise a family on jobs you can't be
outsourced
this is about more than rebuilding our
infrastructure it's about rebuilding our
middle class
i'm so sick and tired i was raised by a
dad not a joke
who when things would go bad i remember
we lived in a we weren't poor but we
lived in a three-bedroom little house
with four kids and a grandpop living
with us
and i looking back on it we thought it
was great but i wonder how my mom and
dad thought about it
because
i remember one night true story
remember and on my my headboard the bunk
bed i was in we had two sets of bunks
in my in our room
and one was up against the wall divided
between my mom's bedroom and ours and i
could tell my dad was restless i could
hear him
i asked my mom the next morning what was
the matter
he said he just found out he lost and
sure we lost our insurance honey we lost
our insurance
well guess what
you are the ones who keep millions of
people from losing their insurance
unions built the middle class we have to
rebuild the middle class
that's why we made sure that the
infrastructure law included significant
labor protections for example
overwhelming the overwhelming majority
of the funds included in this law are
subject to davis bacon requirements
[Applause]
and by the way as you may remember when
i the president obama asked me to do the
recovery act back in our administration
the previous one
we didn't do any you guys didn't do
they wanted the money they had to show
me that they were doing it and
preventing the pain of prevailing wage
as you know that means folks are
rebuilding the country going to earn a
prevailing wage now
and by the way the labor department led
by a proud former president of the
laborers union 223 moddy walsh
good man
[Applause]
if i'm in a foxhole
if i'm in a foxhole i want marty next to
me
look he recently proposed a new
regulation to strengthen prevailing wage
another thing the law does is help
expand registered apprenticeships wasn't
it wonderful when business said don't
worry we'll do the apprenticeships
wasn't that a great generous thing for
them to do early on
well come on man
union partnerships that allow workers to
earn while they learn that matters
because laying a strong foundation
future this country is about more than
having strong roads and bridges ports
and airports that can compete with any
of the world it's also
making sure that here in america
folks who work hard
and live their lives
they have an opportunity to live with
dignity and respect
that's what unions are about my view
about providing dignity and respect for
people who bust their neck that's why i
created the white house task force
on worker organization empowerment to
make sure the choice to join a union
belongs to workers alone
and by the way
by the way
amazon here we come
watch
what
well
that's why i've called on congress to
finally pass the pro act and send it to
my desk
and that's why we're strongly
encouraging grantees to get
infrastructure funding to use use what
we know as the project labor agreements
you know what they are the vast majority
listen to this won't know
which helps ensure the people building
major projects are well trained
highly skilled workers who have a voice
on the work site look
you all know why this matters
union members get higher wages and
benefits like health care and insurance
and paid leave protections against
discrimination and harassment safer
healthier workplaces but there's another
reason
the basic american reason
workers who join a union gain power the
power over decisions that affect their
lives
when you've got a union a workers voices
are heard and heated units provide in
one word democracy in the workplace
organizing joining union that's a
democratic and democracy action an
action
news aren't just good for workers who
join them rebuilding america with union
labor is smart for business in the
american public
and for our entire country
union workers and i'm not just saying
because you're sitting there but give me
my word
you're the best in the world of what you
do
highly skilled
highly trained
you've got a voice in the workplace a
sense of ownership in the project when
union workers are on the job projects
are completed efficiently and they're
completed professionally
that's good for the american taxpayer
it's good for families in every
neighborhood where infrastructure
projects are underway
and so we're going to keep investing in
you and your families
we can and we must do more for example
there are nearly 1.2 million extremely
qualified women who haven't returned to
the workforce there's a simple reason
there's no affordable child care for
them
many families pay up to
in this city and other major cities they
have to 14 000 a year for one child
when i got to the senate as some of you
know
right after i got elected in november 17
and december 18th after that election i
got a phone call saying my wife and
daughter just been killed
a tractor trailer broadside of them and
my two boys were a lot weren't supposed
to make it
my boys did make it thank god but the
point was everybody thinks i commuted
every day because i was his good father
wanting to go that's true but
but
i couldn't afford
daycare
so i had my mom and my sister and my
brother
i had to do it from home
no choice and i was making a good salary
i think at the time we were making 42
000 bucks a year which was a fair amount
of money
i couldn't afford
child care
and these women can't afford to eat if
you cap child care
as i proposed
at seven percent of a family's income
making less than 125 grand a year
it could cut and cost in half the cost
of child care
saving thousands of dollars
and freeing so many people to be able to
go back to work particularly these women
who are totally qualified but have no
alternative to stay home
or take prescription drugs like insulin
many of you know people who have type 1
diabetes another reason for insulin you
know how much it costs to make that
violent insulin
10 dollars ten
ten dollars
but you see families paying on average
over 641 dollars a month
for that insurance up to a thousand a
month
think about those 200 000 kids out there
maybe some of your children who have
type 1 diabetes
200 000
think about what it does to a parent
who looks at their child
doesn't have insurance doesn't have the
cash
and wonders my god
what am i going to do
i have no idea how we're going to pay
for what we need so desperately
it not only puts the child's life in
jeopardy
it strips you of your dignity
how can you look at your child
knowing
they need this but there's no way
you don't qualify for it because you're
making some money but you don't have
enough money to pay for that monthly
bill
it's easy
we can cap insulin
at 35 a month they'll still make 350
percent profit
look
there's so much more we can do if we let
medicaid
be able to do what they do those who are
veterans
they negotiate veterans administration
negotiates
with medicare
for the price for the price they charge
it's a big deal they still make a lot of
money
but what's going on now
we can do it all without adding to
inflation
we don't have to believe me that about
that 17 nobel laureates in economics
in the last six months wrote to me
independently
and said guess what
if you do what you're talking about
it will not only not increase inflation
will reduce the impact on inflation
we can do this without raising a penny
in taxes and anyone making under four
hundred thousand dollars
we have to do it we have to do is ask
the wealthiest americans among us and
major corporations to pay their fair
share just a little bit more
[Applause]
really
not a joke
not a joke
i made a commitment no one making less
than four hundred thousand dollars in my
administration
while i'm president will pay many a
penny more in taxes
that's why i held up the uh the passage
of the of the uh the infrastructure bill
they wanted to add
a a fee for highways
i said no people ordinary people are
going to be paying for that i'm not for
that
we got to have everybody chip in pay
their fair share
look folks
there's no reason why when someone
making 10 million dollars a year
should pay a lower tax rate than a
married couple who are a firefighter
school teacher
but that's how it works
i mean for real
there's no reason why in 2020
the 55 of the company's fortune 500
companies
paid
zero in federal income tax
and they made 40 billion dollars
zero
zero
look i'm a capitalist
if you go out and make a million or a
billion dollars go at it but for god's
sake chip in and pay your fair share
i think
a lot of my
friends are registered republicans
living out there
they think that too
i mean it's just so outrageous
that two trillion dollar tax cut the
last guy what was his name anyway the
last car
i forgot it he never showed up in
inauguration
[Applause]
what all king aside i shouldn't kid
but that tax cut basically went to the
top one tenth of one percent of the
american public
and it didn't grow the economy
look the bottom line is this
the united states is in a position to
out-compete the world once again
if we can keep coming together
invest in the backbone of america
there's no limit on we need to achieve
when i wasn't going to run again as some
of you know you some of my friends
but when i finally decided to run and my
kids encouraged it because anyway it
won't go into that but
if i finally decided to run
the fact of the matter is i made a
judgment we just had a there's no reason
why we have to keep it the way it's been
when's the last time trickle-down
economy has trickled anybody you know
no i'm serious i'm not joking
i'm not joking
so look
i said i was running for three reasons
back then
one to restore the soul of this country
and by that i meant decency and honor
and honesty in what we're gonna do two
to rebuild the backbone of america
to rebuild the backbone of america which
is the middle class and working people
and two
and three to try to unify the country
that's been the hardest thing so far not
a joke but we're going to get there
because you can't have a democracy
function unless you can generate
consensus you ultimately have to unify
it as angry as i sometimes get
so
look america this is a fact
america's always counted on union
workers
and given just half a chance you have
never ever ever not up for you've never
let the country down
we're counting on you
again and you can count on me to keep
fighting for you i promise you
folks
let's continue giving working families a
fighting chance
let's face the challenge ahead
let's keep building a better america
[Applause]
one last thing
we're announcing today
an investment through the infrastructure
law the largest investment in public
transit in american history
20.5 billion dollars
it's going to accomplish two big things
create more good union jobs using
products made in america and reduce
pollution at the same time while making
it safer and easy for folks to get to
work let's keep going let's keep
building let's keep it on the way thank
you thank you thank you may god bless
you may god protect our troops
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
mr president